with a global outreach and create a
global citizenship she is the socialite
turned inmate
a former girlfriend of pedophile jeffrey
epstein and use all the profits to go
back in to pay for things that
governments have a hard time paying for
a close confidant of prince andrew
gillane maxwell has yet to be convicted
of any crime
but her brother ian maxwell believes
she's already being punished i regard
that as torture she is
woken up
every 15 minutes this is a suicide watch
but my sister is not a suicide
risk
in april gillane maxwell's lawyers
released this image of their client with
what appeared to be a black eye her
brother thinks it was the work of a
prison guard
she's lost weight she's losing her hair
we know that she's suffered some kind of
physical abuse because she had a black
eye and
i don't see gilan administering a black
eye to herself so
i'm assuming that that was dished out to
her do you believe that your sister has
been beaten by prison guards i think she
has suffered some
occasional physical abuse at the hands
of her guards yes and we're going to
take it to the u.n take it from me how
is this right how is this just it's
designed to break her
and that is just unjust it is a
fundamental abuse of her human rights
the federal bureau of prisons has said
they take allegations of staff
misconduct seriously and refer all
allegations for investigation if
warranted
jeffrey epstein a friend of presidents
and princes died of suicide in jail in
2019. gillay maxwell denies she procured
teenage girls for him to sexually abuse
these allegations are incredibly serious
they do need to be brought before
accords
the allegations are horrible serious as
they can possibly be
and horrible
and of course that that means that there
has to be
a trial
but at the moment
in the court of public opinion since we
are not in a trial it's going to start
in a month's time
it seems to me that guillen has already
been convicted
ian maxwell has his own memories of
court very relieved to be going home an
innocent man tonight alongside brother
kevin he was acquitted of fraud in a
high-profile trial in 1996. my whole
life was on stop i couldn't travel
passport was taken but i was free
you know i could go about my business
and that's the big big difference
between my brother and i and gillan
jill greenfield represents some of
jeffrey epstein's alleged victims she
has confidence in the u.s judicial
system
the truth will out
and so there's a lot of mystery around
this in a minute isn't that people have
been speculating about what may or may
not have happened but in that process in
that trial process i would expect
that it will really uncover uh what
truly did happen and i think i think in
part everyone's sort of tying themselves
up and not like speculating about it but
if we can once we've gone through the
trial everyone really know what really
did happen
what is your message to our viewers our
viewers who may have read
seen listened to a lot of
stories about your sister imagine if it
was your sister
or your mother or your daughter
banged up 500 days
close
what would you feel about it
you would defend her
you love her you trust her
so
given that
isn't she entitled to the presumption of
innocence isn't she entitled to a fair
trial do you think you'll ever see her
free again
i certainly hope so i'm counting on it
with the trial expected to last more
than a month gelane maxwell is likely to
spend christmas and her 60th birthday in
jail if convicted that today will be far
longer joe pike sky news